[Music]
what is Jenkins Jenkins is an
open-source automation tool that happens
to be developed in Java but how is it
used and what sort of things can it
automate you may wonder simply put it
can basically automate anything they
instruct Jenkins to do but its main use
is for automating tasks in the software
development cycle from code testing at
specific times to move entire projects
to production or staging environments it
is very similar to cron but with a whole
lot more features and accessibility for
its users
I will go more into detail about
everything you can do as we progress
through the course now let's go into the
history lesson
Jenkins originally started as the Hudson
project developed by a company called
Sun Microsystems the Hudson project
success was recognized during the Java
one convention and it was awarded the
software Dukes award in the developer
solution category for those of you who
are not familiar with Java one Java one
is an annual conference organized by
Oracle Corporation to discuss Java
technologies
intrigued by its success Oracle then
later acquired the Hudsons project from
Sun Microsystems after politics disputes
over a project ownership it was then
decided to change the Hudson project
name to Gingka
the dispute between Sun Microsystems and
Oracle Casas split between developers as
well the Hudsons project supporters even
started referring to Jenkins as the for
project of hudson the rivalry continues
on today between Hudson and Jenkins
developers but Jenkins surprises
Hudson's developers by a longshot as
their numbers continue to rise
Jenkins is rapidly becoming a favorite
amongst a modern developer community
there has been a great increase of the
user base and enterprises who are
adopting Jenkins in a continuous
integration environment this increases
cost a big infusion of plug-in
developers who work tirelessly to
continue to make improvements now it's
time to learn some important terminology
and concepts first we're going to
analyze what continuous integration is
but to help us fully grasp the concept
let's look at our typical software
development cycle the five stages of the
software development cycle are the
following first phase is the planning
phase this is where most requirements
are gathered next is the design phase
this is where the technical requirements
are aligned with the specifications
gathered during the planning phase
next comes the coding and implementation
phase this is when the project's handed
off to the developers to start working
their magic and make the project happen
after completion of the coding phase
then comes the testing phase this is
where the primary goal is to find bugs
and correct them before the software is
released finally comes the maintenance
phase during this phase the software is
released to its users this is where a
lot of the bugs that manage to squeeze
through the cracks of the testing phase
start to appear and are corrected with
updates and patches
some of the problems with the standard
development cycle is that it is very
human error prone for example if a
developer forgets to commit the latest
version of the code to the repository
then the rest of the developers are
working on the same project will be
affected causing all kinds of confusion
and delays if no bugs are caught then
buggy software is released to the
consumer once the bugs are finally
identified then is that much more
difficult to fix X number of bugs that
could have been caught early in the
development cycle we do not want a
reactive approach we want a proactive
approach we want the continuous
integration approach
another problem is that it is up to the
developer to catch bugs early in the
process if a developer happens to be
having a bad day
then bugs can be introduced into the
project without anyone to catch it
the goal of continuous integration is to
automate every step of the software
development cycle this allows to be able
to deliver faster more frequently and
much better quality software in other
words CI by nature allows developers to
focus on the project by letting
automation take care of the phases of
the software development cycle which
means less distractions equals better
results and happier developers
how do we get started with CI let's
analyze for some OC ice core principles
to help us implement continuous
integration
our first principle is the maintenance
of a central repository this means that
every developer commits to a central
repository frequently and regularly this
way every team member has access to the
latest version to the project at all
times notice that I didn't specify how
many times or when commit should occur
that is because there really isn't a
determined number that should be
followed every organization would be
different in terms of deadlines and
rules by which new code can be
introduced into the central repository
the main takeaway of maintaining a
central repository is to meet frequently
and regularly the next principle is
automate builds this principle means
that a single command should have the
power of building an entire
infrastructure in this example an entire
section of our website can be rebuilt by
running a single command such as make
space rebuild pages make the command
with the rebuild pages argument the key
takeaway of automate builds is that a
single command should have the power to
build an entire infrastructure next up
is automate testing the idea behind
automated testing is that when a new
commit is performed a test code script
gets triggered and checks the code for
bugs this allows for any bug to get
caught early in the development cycle
and finally our last principle of C is
automate delivery this concept means
that after the project has successfully
passed the code test during the testing
phase then the project through
automation gets moved to staging or a
production server so far we have learned
about continuous integration and other
concepts as well as how to make
decisions is how Jenkins will suit your
organization now let us do something a
little more fun I'll learn how to
install Jenkins so first thing we're
going to do is connect to our server and
there are two commands that are really
long but
just go over them real quick all right
so the first one here is basically
downloads key that we then on the
following command added to this Jenkins
dot list file so we're gonna go ahead
and just copy and paste those commands
into our shell once you copy and paste
this it should return and say that it
went ok so I got the ok here so that
means everything went well so now the
second command gonna copy and paste
have too much space oh you got to give
it a pseudo because this is this is you
know how you have to have administrative
rights to do so so there we go the next
thing is very important always run a
apt-get I mean sudo apt-get update this
will verify that everything is current
in terms of Jenkins and all the packages
let me go ahead and close this other
screen that we don't need anymore so
everything seemed to go well so we can
go ahead and install Jenkins so same
thing as you install any other package
sudo apt-get install Jenkins
I think it was with lowercase J it's
gonna take a few seconds
and it is completed so now you can
verify that Jenkins is installed by
going to etc' in adat the Jenkins status
and same thing as the web server Apache
it'll say that it's active or dead
depending if it's off so now that we
haven't finished the installation on
Jenkins we can go ahead and check out
our new shiny web interface so let's
open up the browser and go to your IP
address of your server the listener is
set to port 8080 for Jenkins so this is
the first screen that you will get it
will tell you that there's a password
located in this file and then we need to
paste it here so let's go ahead and do
that so for this we're going to need
this is that directory is owned by root
so you will need to give it a sudo
command to have access and then cat bar
live Jenkins secrets initial
and this is the password that they're
talking about so we're gonna go ahead
and copy and paste on our web interface
and we can continue we don't want to
save that we can change it anyway so
here you're gonna get two options
install suggested plugins and select
plugins to install I would do the first
option and here's a list of everything
that it will be installed
all right so we can create our first
account and then
all right so we can either save and
finish or we can continue as admin let's
go ahead and do click Save and finish so
we don't have to put that long password
again now we can go start using Jenkins
and here we are we are now in our new
web interface Jenkins so this tells us
our installation was successful
here are the commands and resources that
I wanted to share with you the first one
is the documentation for Jenkins and
then all the commands that I use
throughout the installation process hey
once become an expert in cloud computing
then subscribe to simpler Channel and
click here to watch more such videos
turner it up and get certified in cloud
computing click here